heute waffe häufiger schnitt ihm jemand
das macht die geschichte game master
hätte die ersten tage dieses neun jahre
ist einfach damit verbracht zu hause zu
gehen nicht zu entspannen von der
silvesterparty wieder bisschen
klarzukommen und auch wieder gesund zu
werden soll ja jetzt schon normal wenn
ich mir nicht ganz besondern höhere oder
krank aussehen ich bin doch nicht ganz
über den berg aber dann ist in diese
besinnliche neujahrs städte in diese
traute einsamkeit ein d zug rein
gebrettert mit voller geschwindigkeit
und aus dem leben gesetzt und zwar haben
wir sehr viele von euch geschrieben und
auch sogar andere youtuber das ist also
einen gewissen trend auf youtube gibt
aktuell den ich mir vielleicht mal
anschauen sollte kann jetzt schon so
viel sagen leute dieser trend reiht sich
perfekt in die geschichte von bisherigen
absolut hängengebliebenen youtube trends
ein und ganz vorne dabei ist eine
youtube in die wir auch schon länger
kennen reden wir nicht lange hoben leute
das stichwahl zu der ganzen sache heißt
game master und der erste vorschlag ein
suchbegriff zu dem wort game master ist
natürlich wird mit carolin gut dann
wissen wir auch schon in welche richtung
ist wie die heute geht misst falls ihr
euch jetzt fragt was zum absoluten bist
ein game master dann geht es euch
genauso wie es mir ging paar tagen der
game master ist ein fiktiver charaktere
also eine ausgedachte charaktere den
youtuber benutzen um videos zu faken so
zu tun als will dieser game master
irgendwie in kontakt mit den stehen und
dann diese vollkommen aus
dafür nutzen um den einen oder anderen
klick abzugraben dabei entstehen und
welche videos wie den affenkäfig was
aber die person die am meisten heraus
sticht bei diesem game master unsinn ist
die liebe rebecca ring keine sorge die
land groß viktoria sarina ich sehe ich
auch ich will mir wirklich anfangen wir
aber in diesem begriff einzeln geben
hieß schon so schmerzhaft dem mazda
verfolgt uns im schwimmbad mit ein
bisschen drauf gemalt und dann so eine
komische ändern muss
nur gelegt aber wir sind jetzt auf dem
weg ins kanal und bevor wir wirklich
endlich mal das video anschaut sollte
das so lange dauert heute eine satte
fällt sofort auf wenn man hier drauf
schaut die letzten acht videos denn alle
zum game master und davor hatte sie
einfach in anderen ausgedachten
charaktere 11 und wie schnell hier ist
apple chef von der schärfe von geschäft
also man könnte fast sagen ist so dass
kanal konzept sich einfach irgendwelche
charaktere auszudenken und dann so zu
tun als gäbe es möglich ich möchte ich
kann auch nicht von überhaupt dass ich
mit jedem video die welt die veränderte
aber 11
mehr welcher man fragen wie der video
leute was in eine richtung geht idee von
rebecca ringst bestens kennen und zwar
dass irgendwelche seltsamen kisten oder
so abgelegt werden irgendwo natürlich
von ihr selbst aber sie tut dann sollte
man anders das video das jetzt gehen
soll heißt game master geheime mystery
schatztruhe im dunklen raum vom haus
gefunden
ganz kurz da muss ich schon unterbrechen
er kann nicht böse gemeint jeder kann
auf youtube machen was er will aber wenn
deine zuschauer sich gedanken machen
würde dann hätte dieses video jetzt
nicht 56.000 aufrufe ihr wichtig selbst
als bild auf instagram gepostet habe
game master hatten bild ab in zügen
gepostet
das war natürlich sind unter so einem
container versteckt und darin stand dass
sich um drei und 18 11 und 11
aufschneiden soll
und darin befanden sich richtig seltsame
sachen jetzt ist es schon so weit
gekommen das wäre eine ausgedachte karen
wie viele anderen ausgedachten
charaktere zu schneiden
wir haben im letzten video von itron
angemerkt dieses phänomen nennt sich
gespalten der youtube persönlichkeit und
beim bäcker ring ist hier ein ganz
extremer fall festzustellen befand sich
richtig seltsame sachen richtig komische
dinge wie zb eine plastik schaufel die
so gar keinen sinn macht in dem paket
vom mysteriösen game master war eine
playmobil plastik schaufelt vielleicht
war das ein unterschwelliger hinweis
darauf dass du die vertragen sollte ist
mein burger ich will mit den videos
niemanden persönlich angreifen aber
sorry rebecca die steirer kam von dir
okay ich habe noch ein gemacht das gibt
mir ein bisschen durch was passiert in
dem video
okay aber wieder feinste sv krechting
von rebecca zu bedeuten becky denkt nach
niqab uns bekannt vor
irgendwoher kenne ich das das schlimme
ist wirklich daran leute was mir auch
persönlich in der seele weh tut ist es
so schlecht geschauspielert und die
leute schicken ist trotzdem nicht die
checken sein haben nicht ich glaube die
interessieren sie einfach nicht dafür
auch wahr oder nicht auf der youtube
etwas vorspielt ist dann glaube ich
einfach aber egal was solche kommentare
wie ilike gleich ein mehr mut für sie
ist es ein zeichen dass die g macht sich
hier war ja oder wenn wir ein zeichen
für gespaltene youtube persönlichkeit du
hast deine eigenen dachboden hast dieses
bild dann hängt und kann sich jetzt
nicht mehr reagieren
ok ich glaube wir haben das hier vom
game master gefunden er war hier
befinden sich die zelle hier belassen
lieber gott schickt mir kraft bis 257
und sie ist jetzt dass auf dem dachboden
hat bisher schon mal das ganze video
damit verbracht hast du gesagt hat und
mein gott ich zitter der gamers
nachrichten zu ihm geschickt wie islam
alleingang aber ich glaub ich vergessen
mit einer zahl der auf 532 finden die
nächsten hinweis ab jetzt möchte ich
zeit finde man sich erst mal das finden
also jetzt ganz sicher irgendwann besser
und in dem video passiert glaube ich gar
nicht anders als dem video wo sie eine
mystery boxen ihrer eigenen keller
gefunden hat wo wenigstens noch einfach
gruber chance drin warum man sich die
verluste machen konnte
wenn ich jetzt persönlich echt ein
bisschen beleidigt weil rebecca einfach
nichts zeit schauen wir weiter das ist
jetzt das nächste video das jetzt genau
da an wo das alte aufgehört hat konnte
auf allen strecken gelaufen der stelle
vielen dank für diese kurze sequenzen
record was wir jetzt gerade die perfekte
anwendung gegeben so gut wie jedes game
astrid video weiß ich woher das
wiederkommen aber kleinen schwarzen
koffer machen irgendwie angst kleine
schwarze koffer machen einem angst wer
kennt es nicht flughäfen bahnhöfe die
gerne mal die ganzen kleinen schwarzen
kommen bitte nicht irgendwie gruselig
essen oder komisches oder bitte nicht
das ist so unzufrieden stellen kannst du
nicht einfach wie früher einfach so was
richtig ab sodass der reinpacken nun mal
einfach auf einen schlag so richtig
einfach scheiße früher war auch und
wetter übrigens kanal alles besser leute
das sind die sache einfach besser auf
einen punkt gekommen es war ein video
ausgedachte story findet irgendwie box
im keller oder sind einfach
karnevalsartikel drin
und dieses herzkranke sho
karnevalsartikel drin sind jetzt muss
ich 30 videos gucken ob mögen sie mal
zum ende zu kommen was soll der scheiß
will mich doch verraten was aber steht
hier hieß game master wie ja wohin du
fliegst dimension ist eingekreist eine
station und da muss ich bestimmt hin
das ist das letzte fehlende teil dieses
symbol was sie da gerade das meiner
meinung nach das symbol für
london underground so sieht das aus also
für das straßenbahnnetz in london was
heißt dass sie mit den videos jetzt
nicht nur alle zum shop verhasst wir
nehmen sie irgendwas fehlt irgendwann
story vorspielen die emotionen oder
reaktion verlegt sondern dass jetzt auch
noch in ein anderes land fliegt da fragt
euch was hat das zu bedeuten meine these
ist ich kann es nicht beweisen aber ich
stelle es eine ganz böse vermutung
vermute einfach mal wie gesagt ich
beweise dass becker jetzt nach london
fliegt die flüge nach london
wahrscheinlich noch von der steuer
absetzen wird das heißt sie dem
finanzamt gegenüber behauptet ja es sind
ausgaben für die geschäftsreise dadurch
weniger steuern bezahlen muss ist
vielleicht auch ein bisschen größer auch
in london war hat sie mit diesem genial
masterplan nicht nur 643 1000 leute
verarschen sondern nebenbei auch das
deutsche finanzamt nächstes video dieser
wunderbare reihe ist game master zeigt
sich über facetime an geheimem ort
natürlich habe ich doch gesagt
aber wenn wir es mal einen schritt
zurücktreten heute wer glaubt allen
ernstes von allen menschen auf dieser
welt egal ob sie drei jahre alt sind das
wolbecker wo irgendwelche geheimen
hinweise in ihrem haus bildet und dann
nach london in ein anderes land fliegt
ernsthaft flieht um diesen hinweisen
nachzugehen bitte sag mir das niemand
niemand auf der welt so was glaubt bei
sonsten wir als menschheit einfach
förderung
jetzt wirklich mit nachricht
hinterlassen so zuverlässig genau in dem
moment besser einen hinweis gebraucht
hat und lustigerweise genau in dem
moment wo sie hat vielleicht hat der
meere nachricht geschrieben hatte er
danach ich geschrieben hat dann scheint
mir irgendwie ein zimmer besorgt
wahrscheinlich hat der game master den
zimmern gesorgt
rebecca ohne scheiß wenn du das von der
steuer absetzen althammer ich hoffe dich
sofort vorkommen als normale
steuerzahler mensch hier wie viel glas
kamin ruft an
facetime hallo mein gott oh mein gott
was ist schauspielerei halo the game
hast du ja das ist doch bitte hält
aufgelegt und einfach aufgelegt er hat
an der stelle dann auch keinen bock mehr
im video zu sein max ganz kurze frage
wenn man eine facetime anrufe bekommt
unterschied anonym bei facetime hat man
den kontakt als anonym eingespeichert ja
ja sagst du weg bringen anruf vom game
master bekommt hat sie den game master
als anonyme in ihrem handy
eingespeichert
ja also soweit ich das verstehe super
rebecca person geht weiter heute es ist
einfach endlos gamemaster gefunden und
versucht zu fliehen
er widersteht gemacht
das machte dort geschichte game master
nein rebecca ist es nicht der game
master bitte du bereitest mir schon
herzen bitte höre auf so zu tun und da
ist es wieder
wisst ihr was macht kurz mit plus aus
ich mache mal die monte methode und
schauen mal wie viel werbung und
beschreitet das von video alter was ist
ein fucking ernst 2 3 4 5 6 mit roll
sechsmal wertung im video watch sechsmal
ob diese ganze sache so viel
unangenehmer alter sechs mal während im
video also mal ganz kurz nur zwei mal
werden im video ist normalerweise um 10
bis 15 minuten video zum beispiel bei
drei minuten acht minuten oder fünf
minuten zwölf minuten aber sechsmal
alter das übertrifft baby zu ihren
hardcore zeiten ohne scheiß ich weiß
auch nicht was ich jetzt machen soll
keine ahnung schreibt gespeichert der
youtube persönlichkeit und höhere
beckers videos wirklich irgendwann mal
eine sache noch abgesehen von meinem
kanal gibt es noch einen weiteren gerade
auf dem ich zu sehen bin und dass keine
game master oder 11 und beschert videos
gibt und zwar was das gibt kanal das vor
einigen tagen der jahresrückblick
angegangen der kommt jetzt für euch ein
paar highlights milliarden drauf
gekommen die direkt in der folge und
können sich von dem erholen was wir
jetzt gerade gesehen hat ich könnte mich
ziemlich gut damit aus